Believe the hype.
Spider-Man Across the Spider-verse is somehow
better than the first movie.
This film really just transcends every aspect
of animation and film.
Like obviously the biggest draw here is the
crazily inventive and unique art style that
goes ham in every single frame, but Across
the Spiderverse is also a damn good movie
on its own.
The script is filled with so much heart, emotion,
massive dramatic moments, great twists, the
dialogue is quick, snappy, and so down to
earth and real.
And with all of this and how engaging the
plot of the movie is, it also finds time to
regularly make you laugh with natural jokes
that aren’t forced.
This movie is simultaneously one of the best
dramas, action movies, and even comedies at
times.
The characters feel effortlessly funny and
the charisma exuding from everyone is so palpable.
Basically, everyone here is a standout, but
Miles’ parents get a big emphasis in this
movie and the care they have for Miles spills
out and infects the entire movie making it
deeply endearing.
Because of this, Miles’ drive in the later
part of the movie completely wins you over
and gives you chills from how much great setup
there is.
They spoil the second-act twist in the trailer,
but I’ll refrain from saying it just in
case you don’t know about those plot details.
Then all of this love is contrasted by a great
villain in Miguel O’Hara who’s played
by Oscar Isacc.
He’s so menacing and easily steals scenes
from how big of a presence he is.
He’s also kind of inherently designed as
the antithesis to this movie in that the movie
is really energetic, fun, and fast, but Miguel
is a depressed figure filled with sorrow,
anger, and an once of envy.
The moment he shows up he stands out much
more because of how dark and serious he is.
He contrasts the tone and feel of the movie
and to me this makes him stand out even more
as the villain.
His point of view is completely logical and
his motivation is never in question and is
also right.
These two opposing sides reminds me of Captain
America: Civil War where each side is good,
but they have fundamentally conflicting views
for how they achieve the right thing.
It makes the conflict that much better because
it forces Miles to make groundbreaking decisions
throughout the movie.
He’s not just battling a generic bad guy
with flat motivations, but a character that
forces him to reevaluate who he is as a character
and superhero.
Across the Spiderverse is a surprising 2 hours
and 20 minutes long which is pretty unheard
of for an animated movie.
This means Lord and Miller had no constraints
while making the film they wanted and it really
shows here because they were completely unleashed.
Or everyone who was working on it because
the movie has multiple directors, so it was
probably a deeply collaborative process.
Every setpiece is exploding with vibrant and
crazy energy and I think the set-piece with
all the Spidermen is probably one of my favorite
sequences in a film.
It does not let up for a second and the attention
to detail in every shot is truly staggering.
It was overwhelming but in a good way.
Like no wonder why it took them so long to
make this movie.
Also at no point does the movie feel like
it’s overly utilizing fan servicey cameos.
Because there are definitely cameos within
the movie, but they never feel forced or detract
from what’s going on.
Like there’s so much casual quick moments
that made the theater go wild and the directors
don’t dwell on it for a whole minute like
No Way Home.
The creators know that the story they want
to tell is the priority and don’t want to
cheap out with in-your-face fan service that
halts the momentum.
Also speaking of momentum, the pace is lightning-fast
for 2 hours and 20 minutes.
Which really isn’t a surprise due to the
pace of the first movie, but this could have
been 3-4 hours and I wouldn’t have noticed.
It’s just pure bliss and the splurge in
runtime is refreshing because they can flesh
out more characters like Gwen Stacey.
There’s basically an entire prologue to
the movie that tells her story and that in
of itself was amazing.
It could have ended there as a short story
and I would have been happy.
Also within this segment of the film, the
creators establish a unique visual language
in that each universe has its own distinct
style.
Gwen’s world really utilized punchy and
bright colors that washed over every inch
of the frame.
And they even get creative with matching things
like the background bleeding away while Gwen
is getting upset.
It isn’t an understatement about how revolutionary
and creative this film is for animation and
makes the first film feel like a test run.
Every landscape shot is an instant screen
saver, the transitions are constantly fresh,
they play with the framerate in fun ways again
and how it impacts different characters, the
style of a universe carries over into the
physical character, the action is so well
captured, and the creators are always experimenting
visually.
Unrelated to Spider-Man, there’s this scene
in the show Arcane where a character utilizes
time travel in a fight, and while doing so,
the art style drastically changes and turns
into a beautiful showcase of experimental
animation.
Now imagine this level of creativity but spread
out over 2 hours and 20 minutes.
The action is constantly putting you into
a bewildered state because of this.
Across the Spiderverse is simply one of the
best and if not the best animated movie ever
made in my opinion.
Which is actually a pretty hard title given
Pixar’s lineup.
Those movies may technically have better scripts,
but the presentation of Across the Spider-verse
excels the movie into a league that is incomprehensible.
This is already shaping up to be one of the
highest-rated movies on Letterboxd which really
isn’t surprising.
If I had the option I’d probably give it
6 stars due to how much the animation blew
me away.
I haven’t felt this level of joy and shock
from pure quality in a long time.
Or really not that long since John Wick 4
just came out and that was an action masterpiece.
If this is the level of creativity that animated
movies are heading towards like with how great
the last Puss in Boots was and hopefully the
new Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, then this
is going to be a golden age for animation.
Thank you for watching and for any regular
viewers I’ll put an update about the whole
demonetization situation in the community
tab.
But let me know in the comments if this movie
exceeded your expectations because it somehow
did for me and they were sky-high.